well I think this is a good opportunity
to try to sneak up to the idea of
enlightenment
uh so you wrote a series of good tweets
about Consciousness and pencilism so
let's break it down first you say I
suspect the experience that leads to the
pan psychism syndrome of some
philosophers and other Consciousness
enthusiasts represents the realization
that we don't end at the self but share
a resonant Universe representation with
every other Observer coupled to the same
universe
this actually eventually leads us to a
lot of interesting questions about Ai
and AGI but let's start with this
representation what is this resonant
Universe representation and what do you
think do we share such a representation
the neuroscientist grossberg has come up
with the cognitive architecture that he
calls the Adaptive resonance Theory and
his perspective is that our neurons can
be understood as oscillators that are
resonating with each other and this
outside phenomena
so the course grain model of the
universe that we're building in some
sense is a resonance with objects and
outside of us in the world so basically
we take up patterns that of the
University will be accupeled with and
our brain is not so much
understood as circuitry even though this
perspective is valid but it's almost an
ether in which the individual neurons
are passing on camera electrical signals
or arbitrary signals across all
modalities that can be transmitted
between cells stimulate each other in
this way and produce patterns that they
modulate while passing them on and this
speed of signal progression in the brain
is roughly at the speed of sound
incidentally because the time that it
takes for the signals to hop from cell
to cell which means it's relatively slow
with respect to the world it takes in a
pressurable fraction of a second for a
signal to go through the entire
neocortex something like a few hundred
milliseconds and so there's a lot of
stuff happening in that time where the
signal is passing through your brain
including in the brain itself so nothing
in the brain is assuming that stuff
happens simultaneously everything in the
brain is working in a paradigm where the
world has already moved on when you are
very ready to do the next thing to your
signal including the signal processing
system itself it's quite a different
Paradigm than the one in our digital
computers where we currently assume that
your GPU or CPU is pretty much globally
in the same state
so you mentioned there the non-dual
state and say that some people confuse
it for enlightenment yeah what's the
non-dual state
there is a state in which you notice
that you are no longer a person and
instead you are one with the universe
that speaks to the resonance yes and but
this one with the universe is of course
not accurately modeling that you are
indeed some God entity or indeed the
universe is becoming aware of itself
even though you get this experience I
believe that you get this experience
because your mind is modeling the fact
that you are no longer identified with
the personal self on that state but you
have transcended this division between
the self model and the world model and
you are experiencing yourself as your
mind as something that is representing a
universe so that's still part of the
model yes so it's inside of the model
still you are still inside of patterns
that are generated in your brain and in
your organism and what you are now
experiencing is that you're no longer
this personal self in there but you are
the entirety of the mind on the its
contents why is it so hard to get there
a lot of people who get into the state
think this or associated with
Enlightenment I suspect it's a favorite
training goal for a number of meditators
but um I think that Enlightenment is in
some sense more mundane and it's a step
further or sideways it's the state where
you realize that everything is a
representation yeah you say
Enlightenment is a realization of how
experience is implemented yes so
basically you notice at some point that
your qualia can be deconstructed reverse
engineered what like uh almost like a
schematic of it what what uh
you can start with uh looking at the
face when we look at your own face in
the mirror yeah look at your face for a
few hours in a mirror or for a few
minutes at some point it will look very
weird and you because you notice that
there's actually no face you basically
start and seeing the face what you see
is the geometry and then you can just
assemble the geometry and realize how
that geometry is being constructed in
your mind
and you can learn to modify this so
basically you can change these
generators in your own mind to shift the
face around or to change the
construction of the face to change the
way in which the features are being
assembled why don't we do that more
often why don't we
start really messing with reality
without the use of drugs
or anything else why don't we get good
at this kind of thing like uh
um intentionally oh why should we if I
would because you can morph reality
into something
more pleasant for yourself just have fun
with it
yeah that is probably what you shouldn't
be doing right because outside of your
personal self this outer mind is
probably a relatively smart agent and
what you often notice is that you have
thoughts about how you should live but
you observe yourself doing different
things and having different feelings and
that's because your outer mind doesn't
believe you
and doesn't believe your rational
thoughts well can't you just silence the
out of mind the thing is that the outer
mind is usually smarter than you are
rational thinking is very brittle it's
very hard to use logic and symbolic
thinking to have an accurate model of
the world
so there is often an underlying system
that is looking at your rational
thoughts and then tells you no you're
still missing something your gut feeling
is still saying something else and this
can be for instance you find a partner
that looks perfect or you find a deal
when you build a company or whatever
that looks perfect to you and yet at
some level you feel something is off and
you cannot put your finger on you then
the more reason about it the better it
looks to you but the system that is
outside still tells you no no you're
missing something
and that system is powerful people call
this intuition right intuition is this
unreflected part of your attitude
composition and computation where you
produce a model of how you relate to the
world and what you need to do it in it
and what you can do on it and what's
going to happen that is usually deeper
and
um often more accurate than your reason
so if we look at this as you write in
the tweet
if you look at this more rigorously as a
sort of take the pants like this idea
more seriously almost as a scientific
discipline you write that quote
fascinatingly the pan psychist
interpretation seems to lead to
observations of practical results to a
degree that
physics fundamentalists might call
superstitious reports of long distance
telepathy and remote causation are
ubiquitous in the general population I
am not convinced says yoshibak that
establishing the empirical reality of
telepathy would force an update of any
part of serious academic physics but it
could trigger an important revolution in
both neuroscience and AI from a circuit
perspective to a coupled complex
resonator paradigm
are you suggesting that
um there could be some
rigorous
uh
mathematical wisdom to pan psychist
perspective on the world
so first of all pan psychism is the
perspective that Consciousness is
inseparable for matter in the universe
and I find pan psychism quite
unsatisfying because it does not explain
Consciousness right it does not explain
how this aspect of matter produces it is
also going to try to formalize pen
cycling and write down what it actually
means and with a more formal
mathematical language it's very
difficult to distinguish it from saying
that there is a software site to the
world in the same way as their software
side to what the transistors are doing
in your computer so basically there's
the pattern at a certain core screening
of the universe that in some reasons of
the universe leads to observers that are
observing themselves
right so pen psychism maybe is not even
when I write it down a position that is
distinct from functionalism
but um intuitively a lot of people that
the activity of matter itself of
mechanisms in the world is insufficient
to explain it so it's something that
needs to be intrinsic to matter itself
and
you can apart from this abstract idea
have an experience in which you
experience yourself as being the
universe which I suspect is basically
happening because you manage to dissolve
the division between personal self and
mind that you establish as an infant
when you construct a personal self and
transcend it again and understand how it
works but there is something deeper that
is that you feel that you're also
sharing a state with other people that
you um
have an experience in which you notice
that your personal self is
moving into everything else that you
basically look out of the eyes of
another person that
um every agent in the world that is an
observer is in some sense you so if you
forget that we are the same agent so is
it that we feel that or do we actually
accomplish it so is telepathy possible
is it real is that for me that's just a
question that I don't really know the
answer to in turing's famous 1950 paper
in which he describes the Turing test he
does speculate about telepathy
interestingly and thus himself if
telepathy is real and he thinks that
that variable might be what uh it would
be the implication for AI systems that
try to be intelligent because he didn't
see a mechanism by which a computer
program would become telepathic and I
suspect if telepathy would exist or if
all the reports that you get from people
when you ask the normal person on the
street
I find that very very often they say I
have experiences with telepathy the
scientists might not be interested in
this and might not have a theory about
this but I have difficulty explaining it
away and so you could say maybe this is
the Superstition maybe it's a false
memory or maybe it's a little bit of
psychosis who knows maybe somebody wants
to make their own life more interesting
or misremember something but a lot of
people report I noticed something
terrible happened to my partner and I
know this is exactly the moment it
happened where my child had an accident
and I knew that was happening and the
child was in a different town right so
maybe it's a false memory where this is
later on mistakenly attributed but a lot
of people think this is not the correct
explanation so if something like this
was real what would it mean
it probably would mean that either your
body is an antenna that is sending
information over all sorts of channels
like
um maybe just electromagnetic radio
signals that you're sending over long
distances and you get attuned to another
person that you spend enough time with
to get a few bits out of The Ether to
figure out what this person is doing or
maybe it's also when you are very close
to somebody and you become empathetic
with them what happens that is that you
go into a resonance state with them
right similar to when people go into a
seance and they go into a trend State
and they start shifting a video board
around on the table I think what happens
is that they their minds go by their
nervous systems into a resonant state in
which they basically create something
like a shared dream between them
physical closeness or closeness broadly
defined with physical closeness is much
easier to experience empathy with
someone right it's I suspect it would be
difficult for me to have empathy for you
if you were in a different town also how
would that work but if you are very
close to someone you pick up all sorts
of signals from their body not just via
your eyes but with your entire body and
if the nervous system sits on the other
side and the interstellular
communication sits on the other side and
it's integrating over all these signals
you can make inferences about the state
of the other and it's not just the
personal self that does this by our
reasoning but your perceptual system and
what basically happens is that your
interact representations are directly
interacting it's the physical
um
resonant models of the universe that
exist in your nervous system and in your
body might go into resonance with others
and start sharing some of their states
so we basically buy next to a big next
to somebody you pick up some of their
Vibes and uh feel without looking at
them what they're feeling in this moment
and it's difficult for you if you're
very empathetic to detach yourself from
it and have an emotional state that is
completely independent from your
environment people who are highly
empathetic are describing this and now
imagine that a lot of organisms in in on
this planet have representations of the
environment and operate like this and
they are adjacent to each other and
overlapping so there's going to be some
degree in which there is basically some
change interaction and we are forming
some slightly shared representation and
no relatively few neuroscientists who
consider this possibility I think big um
Rarity in this regard is Mac 11 who is
considering these things in earnest
and I stumbled on this train of thought
mostly by noticing that the tasks of a
neuron can be fulfilled by other cells
as well they can send different typed
chemical messages and physical messages
to their adjacent cells and learn when
to do this and why not make this
conditional and become Universal
functional approximators the only thing
that they cannot do is Telegraph
information over axons very quickly over
long distances right so neurons in this
perspective are specially adapted kind
of telegraph cell that has evolved so we
can move our muscles very fast but our
body is in principle able to also make
models of the world just much much
slower
it's interesting though that at this
time at least in human history there
seems to be a gap between the tools of
science
and the subjective experience that
people report like you're talking about
with telepathy and
it seems like
but not quite there no I think that
there is no gap between the tools of
science and telepathy either it's there
it's not and it's an empirical question
and if it's there we should be able to
detect it in a lab so why is there not a
lot of Michael Evans walking around I I
don't think that Michael 11 is uh
specifically focused on telepathy very
much he is focused on self-organization
in living organisms and in brains both
as a paradigm for development and
there's a paradigm for information
processing and when you think about how
organization processing works on
organisms there is first of all radical
locality which means everything is
decided locally from the perspective of
an individual cell the individual cells
the agent and the other one is coherence
basically there needs to be some
Criterion that determines how these
cells are interacting in such a way that
order emerges on the next level of
structure and this principle of
coherence of
imposing constraints that are not
validated by the individual parts and
lead to coherent structure to basically
Transcendent the agency where you form
an agent on the next level of
organization is crucial in this
perspective it's so cool that radical
locality
leads to the emergence of complexity at
the higher layers and I think what Mike
Levin is looking at is is nothing that
is outside of the realm of Science in
any way it's just that he is a
paradigmatic thinker who developed his
own Paradigm and most of the
neuroscientists are using a different
Paradigm at this point and this often
happens in science that a field is has a
few paradigms in which people try to
understand reality and build Concepts
and make experiments you're kind of one
of those type of paradigmatic thinkers
actually if we can take a tangent on
that
once again returning to the biblical
verses of your tweets
uh you're right my public Explorations
are not driven by audience service
but by my lack of ability for
discovering understanding or following
the relevant authorities so I have to
develop my own thoughts since I think
autonomously these thoughts cannot
always be very good that's you
apologizing for the chaos of your
thoughts or perhaps not apologizing just
identify it but let me ask the question
uh since we talked about
Michael Levin and yourself who I think
are very kind of
uh radical big independent thinkers uh
can we reverse engineer your process of
thinking autonomously
how do you do it how can humans do it
how can you avoid being influenced
by uh what is the stage
stage three
well why would you want to do that it's
uh you see what is working for you and
if it's uh not working for you you build
another structure that works better for
you right and so I've found myself in
when I was thrown into this world in a
state where my intuitions were not
working for me I was not able to
understand how I would be able to
survive on this world and build the
things that I was interested in build
the kinds of relationship I needed to
put work on the topics that I wanted to
make progress on and so I had to learn
and I for me Twitter is not some tool of
publication it's not something where I
put stuff that I entirely believe to be
true and provable it's an interactive
notebook in which I explore
possibilities
and I found that when I try to
understand how the mind and how
Consciousness works I was quite
optimistic I thought I need to need to
be a big body of knowledge that I can
just study and that works and so I
entered studies and philosophy and
computer science and later psychology
and a bit of Neuroscience and so on and
I was disappointed by what I found
because I found that the questions of
how Consciousness and so on Works how
emotion Works how it's possible that the
system can experience anything how
motivation emerges in the mind when not
being answered by the authorities that I
met and the schools that were around
and instead I found that with individual
thinkers that had useful ideas that
sometimes were good sometimes were not
so good sometimes were adopted by a
large group of people sometimes were
rejected by large groups of people but
for me it was much more interesting to
see these Minds as individuals and in my
perspective thinking is still something
that is done not in groups that has to
be done by individuals
so they are motivated you to become an
individual think of yourself I didn't
have a choice obviously I didn't find
the group that thought in a way where I
thought okay I can just adopt everything
that everybody thinks here and now I
understand how Consciousness works right
so or how the mind works or how thinking
works or what thinking even is or What
feelings are and how they're implemented
and so on so to figure all this out I
had to take a lot of um ideas from
individuals and then try to put them
together and something that works for
myself and on one hand I think it helps
if you try to go down and find first
principles on which you can recreate how
thinking Works how languages work what
representation is when the
representation is necessary
how the relationship between a
representing agent and the world Works
in general but how do you escape the
influence once again the pressure of the
crowd
whether it's
you in responding to the the pressure or
you being swept up by the pressure if
you even just look at Twitter the
opinions of the crowd I don't feel
pressure from the crowd I'm completely
immune to that in the same sense I don't
have respect for authority I have
respect for what an individual is
accomplishing or have respect for mental
Firepower or so but it's not that I meet
somebody and gets like God and unable to
speak
um or then a large group of people has a
certain idea that is different from mine
I don't necessarily feel intimidated
which has often been a problem for me in
my life because I like instincts that
other people develop at a very young age
and that help with their
self-preservation in a social
environment
so I had to learn a lot of things the
hard way
yeah
so is there a practical advice you can
give how to think parenting
paradigmatically how to think
independently or you know because you've
kind of said I had no choice
but I think
to a degree you have a choice
because you said you want to be
productive and I think thinking
independent is productive if what you're
curious about is understanding the world
especially when the problems are very
kind of new and open so
it seems like
this is a active process like who can
choose to do that we can practice it
well there's a very basic question when
you read a theory that you find
convincing or interesting how do you
know
but it's very interesting to figure out
what are the sources of that other
person not uh which authority can they
refer to that is then taking off the
burden of being truthful but how did
this Authority in turn know what is the
epistemic chain to observables what are
the first principles from which the
whole thing is derived and
when I was young I was not blessed with
a lot of
um
people around myself who knew how to
make proofs from first principles and I
think mathematicians do this quite
naturally but most of the great
mathematicians do not become
mathematicians in school but they tend
to be self-taught
because school teachers tend not to be
mathematicians right they tend not to be
people who derive things from first
principles so when you ask your school
teacher why does two plus two equal four
um that's your school teacher give you
the right answer like it's a simple game
and there are many simple games that we
could play and
um most of those games that you could
just take different roles would not lead
to an interesting arithmetic and so it's
just an exploration but you can try what
happens if you take different axioms and
here is how you build axioms and derive
Edition from them and build Edition is
some basically syntactic sugar in it and
so this I wish that somebody would have
opened me this Vista and explained to me
how I can build a language in my own
mind and from which I can derive what
I'm seeing and how I can which I can
make geometry and Counting and
um
all the number games that we are playing
in our life and on the other hand I felt
that I learned a lot of this while I was
programming as a child when you start
out with a computer like a Commodore 64
who doesn't which doesn't have a lot of
functionality it's relatively easy to
see how a bunch of relatively simple
circuits are just mostly performing
hashes between bit patterns and how you
can build the entirety of mathematics
and computation on top of this and all
the representational languages that you
need
man Commodore 64 could be one of the
sexiest machines ever built if I still
say so myself if you can return
to uh this really interesting idea
that we started to talk about with
pansychism
sure
and uh the complex resonated Paradigm
and the verses of your tweets
you're right instead of treating eyes
ears and skin as separate sensory
systems with fundamentally different
modalities we might understand them as
overlapping aspects of the same universe
coupled at the same Temple resolution
and almost Inseparable from a single
share resonant model instead of treating
mental representations as fully isolated
between Minds The representations of
physically adjacent Observers
might directly interact and produce
causal effects through the coordination
of the perception and behavior of world
modeling Observers
so the modalities the distinction
between modalities throw that away the
distinction between the individuals
let's throw that away
so what does this interaction
representations look like
when you think about how you represent
the interaction of us in this room yeah
at some level you can the modalities are
quite distinct they're not completely
distinct but you can see this is Vision
but you can close your eyes and then you
don't see a lot anymore but you still
imagine how my mouth is moving when you
hear something and you know that it's
very close to uh the sound that you can
just open your eyes and you get back
into the street merge space and we also
have these experiments where we notice
that the way in which my lips are moving
are affecting how you hear the sound and
also vice versa the sounds that you're
hearing have an influence on how you
interpret some of the visual features
and so this modalities are not separate
in your mind they do are merged at some
fundamental level where you are
interpreting the entire scene that you
are in and your own interactions in the
scene also not completely separate from
the interactions of the other individual
in the scene but there is some resonance
that is going on where we also have a
degree of shared mental representations
and shared empathy due to being in the
same space and having Vibes between each
other Vibes so the question though is
How Deeply interbined is this
multi-modality multi-agent system
like how I mean this is going to the
telepathy question without the
meaning of the word telepathy
it's like how
like what's going on here in this room
right now so it's called epicity would
work how could it work yeah right so
imagine that
um all the cells in your body are
sending signals in a similar way as
neurons are doing right just by touching
the other cells and sending chemicals to
them the other cells interpreting them
learning how to react to them and they
learn how to approximate functions in
this way and compute behavior for the
organisms and this is something that is
open to plants as well and so plants
probably have software running on them
that is controlling how the plant is
working in a similar way as you have a
mind that is controlling how you are
behaving in the world and
um this Spirit of plants which is
something that has been very well
described by our ancestors and they
found this quite normal but uh for some
reason since the enlightenment we are
treating this notion that there are
spirits in nature and there are plenty
of spirits as a Superstition and I think
we probably have to ReDiscover that that
plants have software running on them and
we already did right you notice that
there is a control system in the plant
that connects every part of the plant to
every other part of the plant and
produces coherent behavior in the plant
that is of course much much slower than
the coherent behavior in an animal like
us that has a nervous system that where
everything is synchronized much much
faster by the neurons
but what you also notice is that if a
plant is sitting next to another plant
like you have a very old tree and this
tree is building some kind of
information Highway along its cells so
it can send information from its leaves
to its roots and from some part of the
root to another part of the woods and
there is the fungus living next to the
tree the fungus can probably piggyback
on the communication between the cells
of the tree and send its own signals to
the tree and vice versa the tree might
be able to send informations of the
fungus because after all how would they
build a viable firewall if that other
organism is sitting next to them all the
time and it's never moving away and so
they will have to get along and over a
long enough time frame the networks of
roots in the forest and all the plant
other plants that are there and the
fungi that are there might be forming
something like a biological internet
but the the question there is do they
have to be touching is biology at a
distance possible
of course you can use any kind of
physical signal you can use sounds you
can use electromagnetic waves that are
integrated over many cells it's
conceivable that across distances there
are many kinds of information Pathways
but also our planetary surface is pretty
full of organisms full of cells so
everything is touching everything else
yeah and it's been doing this for many
millions and even billions of years so
there was enough time for information
processing networks to form and if you
think about how a mind is
self-organizing it basically it needs to
in some sense reward these cells for
computing the mind for building of the
necessary Dynamics between the cells
that allow the mind to stabilize itself
and remain on there but if you look at
these spirits of plants that are growing
very close to each other in the forwards
it might be almost growing into each
other these Spirits might be able even
to move to some degree not to become
some number dislocated and shift around
in in that ecosystem right and so if you
think about what the mind is it's a
bunch of activation waves that form
coherent patterns and process
information in in a way that are
colonizing an environment well enough to
allow the continuous sustenance of the
Mind The Continuous stability and
self-depotization of the mind
then it's conceivable that we can link
into this biological internet not
necessarily at the speed of our nervous
system but maybe at the speed of our
body and make some kind of subconscious
connection to the world where we use our
body as an antenna into biological
information processing now now these
ideas are completely speculative I don't
know if any of that is true but if that
was true and if you want to explain
telepathy I think it's much more likely
that such a data telepathy could be
explained using such mechanisms rather
than an discovered Quantum processes
that would break the same model of
physics
could they be undiscovered processes
that don't break yeah so if you think
about
um something like an internet in the
forest that is something that is
borderline discovered there are
basically a lot of scientists would
point out that they do observe that
plans are communicating the forwards or
wood networks and send information for
instance warn each other about new pests
entering the forest and and things are
happening like this so basically there
is communication between plants and
fungi that has been observed well it's
been observed but we haven't plugged
into it so it's like if You observe
humans they seem to be communicating
with a smartphone thing but you don't
understand how smartphone works and how
the the mechanism of the internet works
but we're like maybe it's possible to
really understand the the full richness
of the biological internet that connects
us an interesting question is whether
the communication and the Organization
principles of biological information
processing are as complex educated as
the technology that we've built
they set up on very different principles
right they simultaneously works very
differently in biological systems and
the entire thing needs to be stochastic
and instead of being fully deterministic
or almost fully deterministic as our
literal computers are so there is a
different base protocol layer that would
emerge over the biological structure if
such a thing would be happening and
again I'm not saying here that telepathy
works and not saying that that this is
not who but what I'm saying is I'm I
think I'm open to a possibility that we
see that a few bits can be traveling
long distance between organisms using
biological information processing in
ways that we are not completely aware of
right now and that are more similar to
many of the stories that were completely
normal for our ancestors
well this kind of interacting Interline
representations takes us to the the big
ending of your Tweet series you write
quote I wonder if self-improving AGI
might end up saturating physical
environments with intelligence
to such a degree that isolation of
individual mental States becomes almost
impossible
and the representations of all complex
self-organizing agents merge permanently
with each other
so that's a really interesting idea this
biological Network
life Network
gets so dense
that it might as well be seen as one
that's an interesting uh what do you
think that looks like what do you think
that saturation looks like what does it
feel like I think it's a possibility
it's just a vague possibility and I I
like to explain but um
what is looks like I think that the end
game of AGI is substrate agnostic that
means that egi ultimately if it is being
built is going to be smart enough to
understand how AGI works this means it's
not going to be better than people at
egi research and can take over in
building the Next Generation but it
fully understands how it works and how
it's being implemented and also of
course understands how computation Works
in nature how to build new feedback
loops that you can turn into your own
circuits and this means that the AGI is
likely to virtualize itself into any
environment that can compute so it's not
breaking free from the Silicon substrate
and is going to move into the ecosystems
into our bodies our brains and is going
to merge with all the agency that it
finds there yeah so it's conceivable
that you end up with a completely
integrated information processing across
all Computing systems including
biological computation on Earth you that
we end up triggering some new step and
evolution where basically some Gaia is
being built over the entirety of All
Digital and biological computation
and if this happens then basically uh
everywhere around us you will have
agents that are connected and that are
representing and building models of the
world and their representations will
physically interact they will vibe with
each other and if you find yourself into
an environment an environment that is
saturated with modeling compute where
basically you uh almost every grain of
sand could be part of computation that
is at some point being started by the AI
um you could find yourself in a
situation where you cannot escape this
shared representation anymore and they
will indeed notice that everything in
the world has one shared resonant model
of everything that's happening on the
planet and you notice which part you are
in this thing and you become part of a
very larger almost holographic mind in
which all the parts are observing each
other and formal coherent role so you
lose the ability to notice to notice
yourself as a distinct entity now I
think that when you are conscious in
your own mind you notice yourself as a
distinct entity you notice yourself as a
self-reflexive Observer and I suspect
that we become conscious at the
beginning of our mental development not
at some very high level Consciousness
seems to be part of a training mechanism
that biological nervous systems have to
discover to become trainable because you
cannot take a nervous system like ours
and do stochastic related to centers
back propagation over 100 layers right
this would not be stable on biological
neurons and so instead we start with
some colonizing principle in which a
part of the mental representations
form a notion of being a self-reflexive
absorber that is imposing coherence on
its environment and the spreads until
the boundary of your mind
and if that boundary is no longer
clear-cut because AI is jumping across
substrates and it would be interesting
to see what the global mind would look
like that is basically producing a
globally coherent language of thought
and is representing everything from all
the possible Vantage points
that's an interesting world the
intuition that this thing go out of is a
particular mental state and it's a state
that you find sometimes in literature
for instance Neil Gaiman describes it in
the ocean at the end of the lane and
it's this idea that or this experience
that there is this date in which you
feel that you know everything that can
be known and that and your normal human
mind you've only forgotten you've
forgotten that you are the entire
universe and some people describe this
after they've taken extremely large
amount of mushrooms or had a big
spiritual experience as a hippie in
their 20s and they notice basically that
they are in everything and their their
body is only one part of the universe
and nothing ends at their body and uh
actually everything is observing and
they are part of this big Observer and
the big Observer is focused on as one
local point in their body and their
personality and so on but we can
basically have this Oceanic state in
which we Have No Boundaries and are one
with everything and a lot of meditators
call this the non-dual state because you
no longer have the separation between
surf and world and as I said you can
explain the state relatively simply
without uh pan psychism or anything else
but just by breaking down the
constructed boundary between self and
world and our own mind
but if you combine this with the notion
that systems are physically interacting
to the point where their representations
are merging and interacting with each
other you would literally Implement
something like this right it would still
be a representational state you would
not be one with physics itself it would
still be coarse grained would still be
much slower than physics itself but but
it would be a representation in which
you become aware that you're part of
some kind of Global Information
processing system like thought and the
global mind and a conscious thought that
that coexisting with many other
self-reflexive thoughts
just I would love to observe that from a
video game design perspective how that
game looks
maybe you will after we build AGI and it
takes over but would you be able to step
away step out at the whole thing just
kind of watch
you know the way we can now
sometimes when I'm on a crowded party or
something like this you step back and
you realize
all the different costumes all the
different interactions all the different
computation
that all the individual people are once
distinct from each other and at once all
the same but what we do right we can
have thoughts that are integrative and
we have kind of thoughts that are highly
dissociated from everything else and
experience themselves as separate yeah
but you want to allow yourself to have
those thoughts sometimes you kind of
resist it I think that uh it's not
normative I want it's more descriptive I
want to understand the space of states
that we can be in and that people are
reporting and make sense of them it's
not that I believe that it's your job in
life to get to a particular kind of
state and then you get a high score
or maybe you do I I think you're really
against this high scoring thing I kind
of like yeah you're probably very
competitive and I'm not no not
competitive like role-playing games like
Skyrim it's not competitive there's a
there's a nice thing there's a nice
feeling where your experience points go
up you're not competing against anybody
but it's the world saying you're on the
right track here's a point that's the
game thing it's the game economy and I
found when I was playing games and was
getting addicted to these systems then I
would get into the game and hack it so I
get control over the scoring system and
would no longer be subject to it so
you're not no longer playing your trying
to hack it I don't want to be addicted
to anything I want to be in charge I
want to have agency over what I do
addiction is the loss of control yes
addiction means that you're doing
something comparatively
and the opposite of free will is not
determinism it's compulsion
you don't want to lose yourself in in
the addiction to something nice
addiction to love to the
to the pleasant feelings we humans
experience no I find this uh gets old
right that's you I don't want to have
the best possible emotions I want to
have the most appropriate emotions I
don't want to have the best possible
experience I want to have an adequate
experience that is serving my goals the
stuff that I find meaningful in this
world